This was the correct answer. Fantastic job if you found it. Now if you got stuck
along the way, it might of been at this denominator that gave you trouble. Let's
see how we can find our lowest common denominator first. This denominator
factors to x plus 2 times x minus 1. And then this denominator is actually the
difference of two perfect squares. So we can factor it as X plus 1 times X minus
1. We see the two denominators have a common factor of X minus 1, so we list
that in the middle for our factor tree method. The other factor's on the outside
and then we multiply all of them together to get our lowest common denominator.
X plus 2 times X minus 1. Times x plus 1. Next we want to turn each of these
fractions into an equivalent fraction with the lowest common denominator. This
first denominator is missing the factor x plus 1. So we multiply the numerator
and denominator by it. The second fraction is missing the factor x plus 2. For
this numerator we're multiplying 2 binomials together and we get x squared minus
x minus 2. For the second fraction we're[INAUDIBLE] this 3, the quantity x plus
2. So we have 3 times x which is 3 x and 3 times 2 which is 6. Now that we've
added our numerators together we have a new numerator. And we should always ask
ourselves can we factor this? If we can factor this then we'll be able to
simplify another factor in the numerator and denominator. But in this case, this
numerator can't be factored. There are no factor pairs of 4 that sum to positive
2. This is why we're finished and we can have this as our answer.